This video is made possible by brilliant.
You'll learn more about
brilliant later in today's video,
but if you would like to learn
more about them right now,
it goes a brilliant.org
forward slash biographics.
You'll also find a link
in the description below.
He was America's first and most
celebrated western anti hero.
It was claimed that he kills 21 men,
one for every year of his young life,
and the press portrayed him as a ruthless,
psychotic wild.
I kill it.
The reality was that billy,
the kid,
was none of these things.
I mean this week's biographics,
we go in such of the real early,
there is uncertainty as to the birthplace
of the child who would become a
believer kit.
Most historians believe that
was the slums of New York City,
and the year was 18,
59.
His birth name was Henry Mccarty and he
was the son of Irish immigrants who had
come to America to escape the devastating
effects of the Irish potato famine.
His mother's name was Katherine,
but we know nothing about his father
except that he died when Henry was an
infant.
When Henry was around six and his
mother joins the post civil war exodus,
do the West in such.
If the batter life that had so
far alluded them in the new world,
they drained a wagon train and undertook
the arduous journey over the Oregon
trail.
They go as far as Indianapolis,
Indiana,
there,
Karen and Matt had married a man
by the name of William Harrison.
Trim and trim had dreams of striking it
rich in the gold mines to the southwest.
And soon the makeshift family
had relocated to silver city,
New Mexico,
New Mexico in the early eighties,
seventies was like a foreign
country to immigrants from the east.
It was mainly peoples by
Mexicans and native Americans.
The entire culture and religion was very
different to what most Americans were
used to.
French,
Spanish and Navajo were more
likely to be spoken in English.
And most houses were maces carved
into the sides of rock formations.
In this Hodgepodge of cultures,
violence was commonplace.
What many newcomers from the east would
have recoiled at such an environment,
a young,
uh,
Henry Annacarty.
He embraced it,
immersed himself in the Mexican culture,
spending most of his time in
the Hispanic part of town.
By the time he was a teenager,
he could speak fluent Spanish and
could even pass for native Mexican with
Sombrero and pawn shape.
Whenever that was a public
Mexican social events,
Henry would be that often with his mother.
The two would dance,
the fandango together and talk
easily with the Mexican elders.
Unlike most of the Europeans in town,
Henry showed respect to the
locals exhibiting a formal
politeness to the older
generation,
which one have a lot of praise.
He was remembered by
the Hispanic community,
is a charming boy who was always happy.
The humor was cruelly snatched from
Henry's life when at the age of 15,
he suffered the loss of his mother.
Katherine had been suffering
from tuberculosis for
some time and it was hoped
that the dry air of New
Mexico would say condition,
but it wasn't to be.
Catherine died in 1874,
believing henry and the
possession of his stepfather,
William Antrim.
Andrew,
however,
had no intention of being
tied down with a teenage.
Boys look after he
promptly abandoned 10 read,
leaving town,
and more fertile gold diggings,
so with the age of 15,
Henry was left on his own to fend for
himself in a dangerous frontier town.
Henry now had to live off his wits.
He spends his time hanging around the
saloons and prostitutes on the cds sign of
town,
sleeping in back alleys and boarding
houses and running errands to pay his way.
He soon became involved in minor criminal
activity and meeting up with a hoodlum
by the name of some railroad.
Jack Henry was recruited as a lookout.
Well Jack,
Rob's local businesses.
One of them was the local Chinese laundry.
Things fall apart when a loaded revolver,
that jacket sterling from the laundry,
was found in Henry's possession.
Boy was arrested and
thrown into the local jail.
It was while sitting in that tiny jail
salvage Henry made a fateful decision.
He could have sat and waited for the
circuit judge to come to town and try his
case,
but that may have taken months.
Instead,
he decided to escape.
In doing so,
he honed the skill that would
serve him to good effect.
Many times over the next five years that
was getting people to underestimate his
abilities,
henry talked his God into allowing him
to come out of his cell for a short
period in order to stretch his legs.
He was still confined to the jail house
and the door to the outside world was
security knocks,
but that was also a chimney.
Why does God was out of the room and
we've managed to squeeze this slight frame
up,
the suit covered escape hole and onto
the roof and then into the town plaza.
By the time it was discovered
that he had escaped,
he was free of silver city and en route
to Arizona carrying no food supplies and
without a horse.
Henry displayed an incredible physical
and mental strength in crossing the
desert plains of the southwest.
He quickly learns that
Hampton live off the land,
is foraging where he could
and steaming wearing must.
The 16 year old wanted fugitive,
made it across 500 miles of desert before
stumbling into a remote army outpost
in eastern Arizona.
Gold Camp grads here,
he managed to find employment as a
cook on a local ranch after hours.
He drifted to the local town where he
took the gambling and hustling in the
saloons,
the men and he was now associated with
included some hardened criminals and they
quickly showed him the ropes.
Before long,
he was participating in stealing horses
outside of his ranch duties and
isn't nefarious nighttime activities.
Young Henry,
it founds the time to perfect
his skills with a firearm.
He had managed to buy a revolver and
quickly discovered an innate ability to
wield it.
With this skill came instant
respect for those around him.
Within a year of escaping
the jail cell in silver city,
Henry had developed into a character
of note among the thugs in the Arizona
territory.
He wore a brightly colored scarf
around his neck and walks with the self
assuredness of a man many years
older than his only 17 years,
and it was at this time that people
will begin to call him the kid.
It was August the 17th,
18,
77 when the kid went from small
time crook to hardened killer.
The local blacksmith was a bully by the
name of Frank k hill on that nice while
drinking in a saloon.
Cahill had his sights set on Henry and
he was throwing insults at the kid when
the kid called him a son of a bitch.
Okay.
He'll jumped him and proceeded to
pounds him on the saloon floor.
Pins underneath the bigger man.
The kid managed to free his six shooter.
He shows cahill in the stomach and
then quickly it slid out from under him
leaving the blacksmith to die.
He hightailed it out of town on a stone
and horse and headed back to New Mexico.
Now I wanted fugitive
for the crime of murder.
The kid changed his name
to William h dot Bonnie.
He wandered across the vast open spaces
relying on the hospitality of Hispanic
ranches to provide him with a
meal or a place to lay his head.
Meanwhile,
New Mexico was being targeted by big
shot land speculators from back east.
They sold the mostly barren territory,
is a golden opportunity for speculation,
and they began buying up land
parcels from Hispanic settlers,
usually prices that were
manifestly unfair to the seller.
Those who didn't want to sell that lands
like they were going to find themselves
facing fondant prosecution.
Soon the eastern entrepreneurs had
wrested control of every industry in the
state from mining to the castle industry,
and even the railroads.
The largest county in
New Mexico was Lincoln,
which covered nearly a fifth
of the entire territory.
It was there in 18,
78.
There's a war broke out that would have
a profound effect on the remaining years
of beneath the kid's life.
In the late 18 sixties,
a couple of Irish immigrants by the names
of Lawrence Mathy and James Dolan has
bought up the majority of Lincoln County
and turned it into a huge cattle ranch.
They had secured extremely large
military contracts to supply beef to fort
stands in the Murphy Dolan monopoly,
and Lincoln County was called the house
and it was fiercely protected by battens
of thugs known as the seven rivers gang.
They operated from a huge wooden building
in the middle of the Lincoln township
and controlled every
business in town in 18,
77,
the house monopoly over Lincoln County
was challenged first in court and then on
the range by a Scottish born local
attorney by the name of Alexander Mcswain,
teaming up with a lie.
It was a 23 year old,
recently arrived at British
actress by the name of John Turn,
stall with a seemingly unending
supply of funds to the store,
was intent on creating his own
castle empire in the county.
In this quest,
he enjoyed the support of the most
successful and famous cattle baron in the
entire country.
John Chism tunstall began to recruit
employees not only to work the council,
but also the protection that he knew would
be needed when he came up against the
house.
What are you,
Bonnie?
In Lincoln County in mid 18,
77 and immediately proceeded to do what
he did best and that was steal horses in
short order.
He was caught and thrown in jail.
It just so happens that the man
he had been wrestling horses from.
Well,
that was John Tunstall when the Englishman
confronted the teenage outlaw and
they declined to press charges and steady
off of the kid a job as a member of
the regulators,
the team of cowboys,
that whereas protection squad,
billy,
he grabbed this off,
uh,
with both hands in Johnstown stole.
He had found a man who would
give them a fair break.
He said this,
if his employer Tom Stole,
was the only man who treated
me like I was decent on white.
The kid joins a group of men will older
than him as he learns the work of a
cowboy.
It was a long,
arduous,
often backbreaking work and they slept
sounds with the castle on the range for
the Betas of the house,
Muffy and,
and the idea of an upper crust Englishman
moving in on that territory was
thinkable like the kid's parents that
escape the famine back in Ireland and
deeply resented the English over
their unwillingness to provide relief.
Now,
having found that new life in the new
world where they again to be plagued by
the power and the money
of the English well,
that's something that they
would never allow to happen.
Nothing and Dolan's power extended to
control of the legal system that Lincoln
county operated under.
They enlisted the aid of William Brady,
the corrupt sheriff,
to enforce a fake court
order that confiscated all
of the horses and cattle on
the ranch.
When tunstall received the demands,
he thought it was some kind of mistake
and proceeded to ride into town in order
to sort things out on the way there,
and he was met by the sheriff and a
policy of men on their way to execute the
court order.
Still thinking he could reason with
the Lumen to install road towards the
sheriff.
But before he got twice
members of the policy,
they shot him dead.
To add insult to injury,
they shot his horse to install.
His body was soon found by the men who
worked for him and taken back to his
ranch for burial.
Billy was incensed at the cold blooded
assassination of his boss and he,
along with a group of
hardcore other employees,
made a pact of vengeance
against the house.
They made it to the top of which
was the sheriff of Lincoln County.
William Brady Brady's ends
came on April fool's day.
18,
78 says he was taking his
morning stroll through Lincoln.
Billy and his fellow regulators were
lying in ambush and poured more than a
dozen bullets into his body during
the gunfight that ensued with Brady's
deputies.
Billy was shot in the
thigh three days later.
A shootout occurred.
It blazes mill this time to have the
regulators were killed as a result of the
two incidents,
several murder warrants were
issued including one for billy.
The conflicts came to a head when
Alexander Mcqueen road from the ton store
ranch with between 50 and 60
regulators on July the 14th,
18,
68.
Some of the men's strategically positioned
themselves between buildings and on
rooftops while others including billy,
set themselves up in a house that belonged
to McSweeney for the next two days.
They waited on July the 16th.
The new sheriff George happens,
send some men to kill the regular
agency were stationed on the roof of the
saloon after one of them,
but was killed.
These men were forced to retreat.
Heaven.
Now send a message to fort stands
in requesting military assistance.
The request was initially turned down,
but the military bras changed their mind
the next day with that Nathan Dudley
road into town at the head
of a troop of soldiers,
a standoff in sued for a couple more days.
Then on Friday,
July,
the 19th,
all hell broke loose.
The regulators were now
all hold up in the house.
A massive barrage of firepower was
unleashed on this house with return fire
coming just as fiercely.
Then the house was set on fire
and then attempts to escape.
Alexander Mcswain was shot dead that he
managed to kill the man who had felled
mcswain before making good on his own
escape along with the other regulators.
Now,
just before we get into
the rest of billy's life,
I do want to take a moment to thank the
people who make this video possible and
that will be brilliant.
I know mid rollout is not
great for the story here,
but these videos are long,
so I do hope you appreciate our needs
to have sponsors to make them possible.
Brilliance.
Our lending platform,
which teaches three something
called active learning,
unlike biographies,
which has done a nice way to
learn about people's lives,
learning about science.
It's a bit trickier.
I don't know if you've ever had to
sit down with a science textbook.
I have and I read them
in a whole lot of stuff.
That makes me think,
hold on a second and then you ended
up reading the page six times over and
you're still not taking it in.
Well,
brilliant.
Solves that problem with active learning,
Giving you something super short to read.
It's really easy and then you
immediately apply it to a problem.
The rinse and repeat that and suddenly
or understanding or sorts of stuff that
you really didn't think you'd be able to.
I've been using.
Brilliant and you should just go try it.
Just to see how easy it is to suddenly
be understanding all of these complex
subjects.
It's really brilliant.
Just make them super easy to grasp.
You can support biographics by going to
brilliant.org forward slash biographics,
and now let's get back to the kid.
Bye now developed into a seasoned killer.
He was now wanted for multiple counts
of murder in different jurisdictions.
Still,
he was able to find refuge with the
Hispanic sheepherders who viewed him as a
fighter for their liberty
against the Anglo robber barons.
The firestorm that had erupted in the
heart of Lincoln County forced authorities
to act in diamonds were issued for the
arrest of billion to other regulators for
the murder of sheriff braiding.
I knew governor of New Mexico territory
was also appointed the man given the job
was new wallace,
a format union,
army general and future
author of the Book Ben Hart,
Wallace that Alpha Lincoln County with
direct instructions from President
Rutherford b Hayes to restore order.
But while it's encountered a population
who were too terrifying to get involved
in so was unable to secure any witness
testimonies as to what had been
occurring,
that he received a letter
from a man calling himself,
William H,
Bonnie.
The kids offered to testify against
the members of the house in return for
philanthropists and swallows,
agreed,
believe,
testified before a grand jury with his
testimony leading do indictments against
a number of house members
including leader James Donut,
but he hadn't lived up
to his side of the deal,
but unfortunately the governor did not
live up to his skipping town before the
amnesty.
You could be formalized
with the governor gone.
Most of the indictments
against the house members,
they would drops,
but those against the regulators,
they remained,
believe fled town before
he could be arrested.
While the other regulars
fled in New Mexico territory,
billy decided to stay put and you can
also living as a council on Horse Rustler
over the next few months.
See arrestee ranches.
If the house empire and the
process becoming the most
wanted man in New Mexico,
the newspapers of New Mexico,
most of which were simply
mouthpieces for the house,
demonized the blaming him for every
misdeed in the territory in 18,
80,
the editor of the Las Vegas,
because that first names the outlawed,
believe the kids,
the name for which he would forever.
You know,
by the summer of 18,
80 though,
he still rooms the territory.
Billy had made a base for
himself at Fort Sumner,
some 100 miles from Lincoln.
Why now?
Lincoln had a new sheriff and
his name was pat garrison.
He was single minded with his
obsession to capture billy the kid.
Garrett was a tenacious,
determined man.
He and his posse tractability and
his gang over the winter of 18,
82 of the outlaws were killed in a
shootout with the others being cornered in
cabinets,
a place called stinking springs.
After attempt standoff believe finally
came out with his hands in the APP.
The kid was transported by train to Santa
Fe and put on trial for the murder of
Sheriff Brady.
He was found guilty and sentenced to
death by hanging the next and supposedly
last stop was Lincoln where he was housed
in a second story room of the bank and
county courthouse.
It was there that he was to
wait for his date with the news,
but well billy,
he had other plans on April the 28th,
18,
81 in the early afternoon.
Billing told us God that
he needed to use the privy.
The guard escorted him in shackles to the
outhouse on the way back as he went up
the stairs to his room,
but he managed to slip out
of his hand and shackles.
He turns and wrestled with the gods,
managing to grab his gun.
The mountains tend to flee,
but believe shot him dead.
The kid then made for one of the rooms
in which he knew there was a shotgun.
Quickly loading it.
He ran through a window and looked
down on the street to see another God,
Bob [inaudible],
who had been eating his lunch across the
way comes from wanting to investigate.
Billy called out hello barb,
before blasting him with
both barrels with both gods,
dad,
billy.
Then race downstairs.
He commandeered a horse and was away,
but he's daring escape,
made them the most famous
outlaw in the country,
but it also made him a
three time cop killer.
This changed Garrett's mind now.
He wanted to hunt him down
and kill him despite this,
and he chose to remain in New Mexico.
The reason being is that he had fallen
in love with a 16 year old girl by the
name of polly to Maxwell back in Lincoln.
Garrett was receiving information
as to the whereabouts of the kit.
They were being supplied by the older
brother of police at peace maxwell who was
not happy about this romance.
He told Gary that billy
was in Fort Sumner.
Garrett finally moved on the intelligence
he stole into Fort Sumner on the
evening of July 14th,
1891 with two deputies alongside him.
They went straight to the home of the
maxwells posting the two deputies on the
front porch.
She entered the house from the back and
made for the bedroom of peet maxwell.
At this very moment that he was
approaching the porch in the dark,
he could only just make out the shape of
the two men there and he called out who
is it,
but there was no reply at this belly.
Cautiously backs through the open doorway
inside garrison maxwell were sitting
on the bed on seeing the figure.
Maxwell leaned over and
whispered to him garret levels,
his six shooter and fired.
Then either kids fell,
dad's never knowing who
had fired the fatal bullet,
so I really hope you found
this video interesting.
If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button below.
Don't forget to subscribe.
Brand new videos just like
this two times a week.
Also,
do checkout brilliance.
You'll find a link to them
in the description below,
and as always,
thank you for watching.